je travaille au musée de vilel je fais
partie également d'une association qui
s'appelle l'association qutilel créée en
1993 dont le le but est entre autres
était aussi de créer une passerelle
entre le musée et le camp
le camp villel qui était anciennement le
camp d'esclav de Madame de bassin
démocratiser un petit peu faire
comprendre aux gens que le musée ça fait
partie de notre patrimoine mais qui sont
libres en quelque sorte de venir ici
profiter de de ces lieux notre
association enquête de son histoire de
son identité de Jean villel a fait une
recherche
généalogique à travers de plusieurs
familles notamment la famille Carlo et
il faut savoir qu'en 1848 à laabolution
de l'esclavage c'est les nouveaux libres
qui avait seulement un prénom en tant
qu'esclave vont recevoir un patronyme et
on a retrouvé le patronyme tarlot sur la
liste des esclaves à franchi en 1848
mais ce nom Carl existe encore à villel
on a étaé voir une famille notamment
monsieur Carlos
jeanarsen qui est né en 1969 il habite
aujourd'hui à poillou et on a fait les
recherches généalogiques avec un peu de
chance on peut dire on est remonté
jusqu'à très très très loin et on est
retombé c'était une grande satisfaction
à nous hein qui ne connaissaiit pas
vraiment notre histoire on est retombé
sur Véronique et Véronique était
infirmière à l'hôpital des esclaves elle
avait 71 ans en
1845 et ça c'était vraiment une très
très belle découverte cette généalogie
on on voulait le mettre en valeur et
dans le cadre de du 150e anniversaire de
l'abolution deesclavage en
1998 on a fait appel à une une artiste
anne-emarie Valencia on a eu la la
chance de travailler avec elle une
artiste qui est qui a pris à cœur sur
son son son travail et
elle résidait pas très loin à côté de
l'église de saint-giléo et à l'occasion
aussi on a profité
pour que qu'il puisse faire aussi le
portrait de Arsen Carlo on lui a remis à
Arsen un portrait en guide de de
collaboration de de souvenir anemarie
Valencia a fait cette œuvre et l'idée
aussi quand on quand on regarde cette
œuvre de voir que c'est très c'est
sombre ici hein c'est vraiment sombre ça
nous cette période de l'obscurité de
l'esclavage et cetera une époque très
difficile et plus on monte sont pas vers
la vers vers la
lumière